CALL ME THE ORDER AND WE'LL
START THE MEETING -- LACKING A
QUORUM AND WILL TAKE ROLE ONCE
WE GET TO CORN BUT IN TERMS OF
DIFFERENCE TO DO TO US
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I WANT TO
PRESENT BILLS.
AND WE HAVE NINETY WE HAVE A
GOOD AGENDA TODAY WILL START THE
HEARING.
AND START TAKING TESTIMONY SO --
WOULD LIKE EVERYBODY -- TO OF
COURSE -- TAKE CONVERSATIONS
OUTSIDE THE CHAMBERS BECAUSE
THIS IS A ECHO CHAMBER ACTUALLY
IT'S NOT A SECTION ECHO CHAMBER
I CAN HEAR EVERYTHING IS STOCKED
IN THE BACK ROAD.
YOU KNOW SOME KIND OF
INTERESTING THAT SOMETIMES I CAN
HEAR THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON
DOCTOR.
WAY UP HERE -- NEED YOU GUYS TO
WRITE.
YOU CAN HEAR PEOPLE TALK ABOUT --
WE WANT TO SELL TONE PHONES OFF.
NOW IN TERMS OF OUR AGENDA WE
HAVE -- THREE ITEMS THAT ARE OFF
IN THE WILL BE TAKEN UP AT A
FUTURE MEETING.
AND THAT'S AB.
ONE ONE TWO AB.
THREE OH NINE AND ACR THIRTY
SEVEN SO WE'RE WORKING ON THOSE
RIGHT NOW -- I SEE ONE OF OUR
ARTISTS HERE IN ONE OF THOSE
BILLS ARE GONNA BE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THOSE.
CAN TAKE HIM UP AT A FUTURE
MEETING -- I ALSO ANNOUNCED WE
HAVE CONSENT CALENDAR -- WHICH
CONSIST OF A BEEF. TWO FIFTY TWO
AB.
THREE THIRTY FIVE SB.
SIX THIRTY FOUR AB.
NINE NINETY EIGHT A. B.. ONE
ZERO EIGHT NINE AN AB -- ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE THAT'S CONSIDERED
CONSENT CALENDAR A CONSENT
COUNTER BE OURS -- RESOLUTIONS
ACR FOR EASIER THIRTY EIGHT HE'S
HERE FORTY FOUR ACR.
FORTY SEVEN AND ACR SIXTY SIX
NOW THE REASON WE'RE DOING TO
CONSENT COUNTERS FOR THE MEMBERS
IS.
THERE'S BEEN REQUESTED VOTE ON
THEM SEPARATELY SO.
IS GONNA TWO VOTES ONE ON THE
FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN
A SECOND VOTE.
ON THE SECOND SECONDS.
OKAY THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
ANYTHING WITH A A. B.. TWO FIFTY
TWO THREE THIRTY FIVE SIX THIRTY
FOUR AB NINE NINETY EIGHT A. B..
TEN EIGHTY NINE AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE THAT'S THE FIRST ONE THE
SECOND ONE OR ALL THE HOTELS THE
P. C. OURS.
HE'S HERE. FOR THIRTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN AND SIXTY
SIX OKAY.
ACR -- SEVENTEEN WILL BE HEARD.
ACR THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST A
HEARING ON THAT [inaudible]
ONE OKAY.
NO NOT YET.
WE'LL GET IT A FEW MINUTES.
OKAY THANK YOU -- IS AND SO
THOSE ARE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS EVERYBODY SHOULD BE AWARE.
THAT THAT'S HAPPENING -- WILL
GET RIGHT INTO IT WILL TAKE UP
THE FIRST ITEM A P. B. -- EIGHT
EIGHTEEN HOUR OR ONE EIGHTY FIVE
AND WE'LL HAVE THE OFFER COME
FORWARD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
CENTERS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
AB ONE EIGHTY FIVE PROMOTE
SMARTER TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO PARTICIPATE IN
JOINT MEETINGS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
AND THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD AS
HOUSEHOLDS ARE DRIVEN FROM JOB
IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS TOWARD
MORE AFFORDABLE AREAS.
THEY'RE FACED WITH LONGER
COMMUTE TIMES RESULTING IN
GREATER POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY INCLUDING EIGHT
CD AND THE A. R. B. IN THESE
MEETINGS.
FUTURE TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
CAN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WILL LAND
USE DECISIONS GROWTH PATTERNS
AND THE AVAILABILITY OF JOBS AND
HOUSING WHICH IS A NECESSARY
STEP IN COMBATING THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING SPRAWL.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THE
TRIPLE CHALLENGE OF PROMOTING
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY LIMITING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
MAINTAINING OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE
GENERAL HAVE MY WITNESS SELF
INTRODUCE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DAHLE
AND MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS -- JOE FOR BOROUGH AND
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION -- FOR
TWENTY TO SAY OUR DEEPEST
APPRECIATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING UP
THIS RECOMMENDATION BY THE
COMMISSION IN OUR ANNUAL REPORT
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT OUR INAUGURAL MEETING LAST
YEAR IN JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WITH THE STATE RESOURCE -- EVERY
FOR SPORT AND THE COMMISSION.
IT WAS EVIDENT FROM TESTIMONIES
FROM OUR COMMISSION MEMBERS
BOARD MEMBER STAKEHOLDERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
THAT A KEY VOICE WAS MISSING IN
THE DISCUSSION AND THE GREATER --
LANDSCAPE OF LOOKING AT THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
TRANSPORTATION AND OUSING GOALS.
THIS IS WHY THE COMMISSION --
FACILITATED THIS --
RECOMMENDATION AND GIVING DE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN HOUSING AND
LAND USE POLICY SUPPORT THESE
GOALS WE BELIEVE THAT ATVS
PARTICIPATION IN THESE JOINT
MEETINGS.
CRITICAL FOR POLICY DISCUSSIONS
ON ISSUES SUCH AS LAND USE
DECISIONS CROWD PATTERNS BUT
SOLICITING AND PERMITTING.
WE APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS --
LEADERSHIP IN THIS EFFORT AND
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS MAY HAVE AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU AND WE ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
PLEASE.
WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
YES SIR.
JOE CRUISE ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS APPRECIATE THE WORK
THE AUTHOR AND WE ARE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
OTHER SPEAKERS -- DO WE HAVE
OPPONENTS.
BONUS COME FOR PLEASE.
NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
NONE.
JUDGE CLOSE.
MISTER CHAIR AND CENTERS I
SIMPLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU WILL TAKE UP TO VOTE
WHEN WE HAVE A RICH CORN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
NOW CAN OKAY NO MOTIONS TO WE
CALL -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
YOU MAY COME FORTH.
YOU HAVE A PACKAGE OF BILLS YOU
WANNA START ON WHICH ONE WE'LL
GO IN FILE ORDER OKAY VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND THEN WE'LL
START WITH ITEM. THREE TO EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU FIRST
OF ALL I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND STUFF. FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY PUT INTO THIS BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
STOP AND AMENDMENTS PURSUANT TO
PAGE FOUR OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
BUT BECAUSE OF TIME AND WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING THEM IN THE NEXT
POLICY COMMITTEE -- AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S
LONG TERM TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING DOCUMENT TO INCORPORATE
CURRENT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION GOALS SUCH AS SB
THIRTY TWO AND THE STATE'S AIR
QUALITY PLANS.
AND WE ALL KNOW THE DIRECT
EMISSIONS FROM HELL THE TROOPER
FROM TEL PIPES FROM ALL SORTS OF
VEHICLES ARE A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR
TO R. G. H. G. INVENTORY AND AND
WHAT ONE DIRECTION IN THE STATE
WE'RE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
WITH THE AIR QUALITY TO MISSIONS.
ARMED WITH A 2% INCREASE BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND NOW.
THIS UPDATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IS LONG
OVERDUE AND WOULD FOR IMPROVE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS WE EXPECT OUR
COMPANIES AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY
TO RESPECT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
AND WE SHOULD EXPECT NO LESS
FROM OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES THEY
SHOULD BE -- IN KEEPING WITH THE
GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENACTED WITH ME TODAY AND
SUPPORTERS WILL BEAR WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
ROCKING COULD NOT RUSHING WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR --
JUST TO BE CLEAR AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND I REQUEST REQUEST
FULLY REQUEST REQUEST YOUR
HIGHEST CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
I'M ABOUT ALL GO TO MY WITNESS
AGO SEVEN WOMAN -- WILL TAKE US
TWENTY PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
WILL BEAR AND WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WE THINK IT'S A COMMON
SENSE -- MEASURE TO UPDATE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS -- THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATIONS
TWENTY NINETEEN STATE OF THE
ERROR REPORT FOUND CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO SEVEN OF THE TEN MOST --
SMOG POLLUTED CITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND ALSO WE SAW THAT -- THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE OR
MAKING OUR JOB OF CLEANING UP
THERE THAT MUCH HARDER.
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ESPECIALLY
PASSENGER VEHICLES IS THE
LEADING SOURCE OF POLLUTION BOTH
ON THE A CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE
FRONT.
THIS BILL INSURANCE OF THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS ACCOUNT FOR
TREATMENT OF OUR CLEAN AIR ACT
AND STATE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION RESPONSIBILITIES WILL
ALSO IDENTIFYING.
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALIGN
TRANSPORTATION GRANT PROGRAMS TO
BETTER SUPPORT THE POLLUTION
BENEFIT PRODUCTION BENEFITS WE
NEED.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES AN
ASSESSMENT OF REGIONAL
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
TO EVALUATE.
HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
PLANS WILL INTEGRATE WITH THE
OVERALL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
THE CALIFORNIANS DESERVE?
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
MOVING CALIFORNIA FORD IN
ENSURING THAT ALL SECTORS ARE
REDUCING HARMFUL POLLUTION WELL
BUILDING HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IMPORTANTLY AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE
CREATE SPACE FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CONCERNS WITHIN THE
PLAN'S GOING FORWARD IN
RECOGNITION THAT MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY TRANSPORTATION
POLLUTION -- GIVEN THE URGENCY
OF ACHIEVING OUR HEALTH
PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY CLIMATE
STANDARDS WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE IS A AGAIN A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH.
TO UPDATING THE PLANTS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT NEW MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ROCKY RUSSIAN I'M WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
AND A WE SUPPORT A. B. TWO
EIGHTY FIVE THE HARMFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH IMPACTS
OF TAILPIPE EMISSIONS ARE
IRREFUTABLE.
WHETHER IT'S MOM OR MOM OR DAD
SOCCER VANDALS A DELIVERY
DROPPING OUT PACKAGES IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR AN EIGHTEEN
WHEELER ROLLING DOWN THE FREEWAY.
WE ARE POPPING TOXIC CHEMICALS
IN OUR AIR THAT ARE HEATING UP
OUR CLIMATE MAKING PEOPLE SICK.
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES ACCOUNT
FOR APPROXIMATELY 80% SMOG
FORMING KNOCKS EMISSIONS 90% OF
DIESEL PM.
AND APPROXIMATELY HOW FAR
GREENHOUSE GASES IN CALIFORNIA
THESE POLLUTANTS IMPACT AIR
QUALITY IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CONTRIBUTING TO A WIDE RANGE OF
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
INCLUDING AS MY TAX E. R. VISITS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
HEART ATTACKS STROKES AND
PREMATURE DEATHS.
CARBON POLLUTION FROM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM DRIVES
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
CONDITIONS FOR EXTREME HEAT.
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRES.
YET THERE IS A SERIOUS
DISCONNECT WITH OUR AIR QUALITY
CLIMATE GOALS IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
WE ON THE PATH TO FAILURE IN
MEETING OUR GHG REDUCTION TARGET
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
UNLESS WE SOLVE THE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING PLANNING
CONUNDRUM.
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR SUPPORTS
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE BECAUSE IT
WOULDN'T SURE THAT CURRENT.
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE STANDARDS
ARE ACCOUNTED FOR WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
AB TWENTY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
CALTRANS TO ADDRESS HOW WE WILL
REACH THE NECESSARY EMISSION
REDUCTIONS NECESSARY TO ME CLEAN
AIR REQUIREMENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA IS TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE STANDARDS IN FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS FUTURE
PLANS WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
CONSIDERATIONS AS MY COLLEAGUE
WILL POINT IT OUT.
THERE'S CRITICAL NEED TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS AND INVESTMENT SUPPORT
REDUCTIONS IN THE POLLUTANTS
THAT THREATEN THE HEALTH OF TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE WOULD
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
MEETING THIS NEED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MARSHALL HERE SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
YES SIR MR CHEN MEMBERS FROST
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT A TO THINK THE OFTEN
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
SOME TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
THANK.
MICHAEL DRAFT WITH THE PRAYING
MIKKELI ON BEHALF OF CHARGE
POINT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CATHERINE
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU -- TO HAVE OPPONENTS
OF THIS BILL COME FOR PLEASE
[inaudible]
ANYBODY OPPOSED [inaudible]
SEE NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
A QUESTIONS.
OF ALL THROUGH MY CLOTHES.
JUST A AGAIN THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE HEARD A
LOT OF SUPPORT FROM IT FROM OUR
DIFFERENT PLANNING AGENCIES AND
OUR LOCALITIES AND SUPPORT TO
GET CITY AGENCIES ON THE SAME
PAGE I WOULD REQUEST FULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
WHEN A TOTAL -- TAKE A BILL UP
SHORTLY WHEN OF COURSE.
IT WILL GO ON YOUR NEXT BILL
WHICH IS ITEM. TEN ELEVEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL.
TRANSPORTATION CONTINUES TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST
CONTRIBUTOR OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR NOW ACCOUNTS 440% OF THE
STATE'S TOTAL EMISSIONS.
AND WE'RE JUST NOT ON THE RIGHT
TRAJECTORY.
CARBS SB ONE FIFTY REPORT
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO PREVENTING THE
STATE FROM MEETING ITS
TRANSPORTATION GOALS ONE WAS AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE DATA THAT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
ACCURATE -- PLANS FOR TEA AND
SEES AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA'S NPOS TO
INCLUDE METRICS ABOUT TNC IS AS
PART OF THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS TO INCLUDE
MEASURES REGARDING BARRIERS TO
THE UTILIZATION OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT INCLUDING TRANSFERRED
FREQUENTLY.
SURE OF FREQUENCY PARKING OF
SAUDIS FOR BICYCLES.
IN ADDITION AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
DIRECTS THE CPUC TO CONSIDER THE
NEEDS OF NPOS AND OTHER STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES IN PLANNING
AND MEETING THEIR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY GOALS.
WHEN DECIDING ON TNC DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS?
M. P. O.'S ANOTHER TRANSIT INTO
ENTITIES NEED APPROPRIATE DATA
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES
THAT WILL REDUCE THE USE OF
SINGLE OCCUPANCY VEHICLES.
INCREASE PUBLIC TRANSIT
UTILIZATION AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
THIS UPDATE TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANS
AND ADDING DIRECTION TO THE C.
P. UC'S REGARDING TNC DATA
REPORTING WILL IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TRANSPORTATION
POLICIES AND PLANS.
I WILL HELP CALIFORNIA MINUTES%
LONG TERM TRUCK CLIMATE IN ITS
TRANSPORTATION GOALS.
WITHOUT JUST TODAY WE RECEIVED A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION FROM T. AND
SEES AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM GOING FORWARD.
IN THE SENATE YOU AND SEE
COMMITTEE TO FINE TUNE THE CPUC
PART OF THE BILL IN OUR INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS DOABLE AND WE WOULD ASK
FOR THE RESPECT TO ALLOW THIS TO
MOVE FORWARD TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
SO WE CAN WORK WITH THEM I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
IMPORTANT ISSUES HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE SP ONE FIFTY REPORT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROTECTING USER
PRIVACY.
AND NOT IMPOSING OVERLY OWNERS
REQUIREMENTS ON THE TNC IS WE'RE
REALLY OUT TO HELP THEM HELP
EVERYBODY GETTHE LOCALITIES GET
CITIES THE DATA THAT THEY NEED
SO THAT THEY CAN PLAN
EFFECTIVELY.
WITH THAT I WILL -- INTRODUCE MY
WITNESSES -- RICHARD MARX AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF CIVIL ENGINEERS REGION.
NINE AND SELENA REYNOLDS GENERAL
MANAGER OF LA DOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RICH
MARKETS AND ON BEHALF OF A AS C.
E. -- GOOD DATA MAKES FOR GOOD
DECISION MAKING AND THE
PROVISIONS IN ELEVEN FORTY TWO
THAT -- WILL ALLOW THE
COLLECTION OF AGGREGATE DATA AND
PROVIDE THAT TO THE NPOS IN
MAKING THEIR DECISION MAKING --
WHICH IS MANDATED UNDER STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW MAKES GOOD SENSE
FOR CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED [inaudible]
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS LEADER
RENTALS LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION GENERAL
MANAGER ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER SEVENTY OF THE
LARGEST U. S. CITIES IN THEIR
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENTS --
KNECHTEL AS LONG BEEN A CHAMPION
OF POLICY MAKING IN DAYLIGHT AND
CITIES NEED TO HAVE --
VERIFIABLE DATA IN ORDER TO MAKE
SMART DECISIONS AS THE PRIMARY
ENTITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING THE PUBLIC REALM
TOWARDS BIG GOALS LIKE SAFETY --
CLIMATE AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY IN
EQUITY DATA IS REALLY OUR
LIFEBLOOD TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES -- BREATHE IN AND
BREATHE OUT DATA ON AN EVERYDAY
BASIS WE'RE ACCUSTOMED TO USING
IT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES ON OUR STREETS FOR MANYYEARS -- THE THE TNC THEMSELVES
HAVE HAD A NARRATIVE THAT THEY
HAVE -- EXISTS TO FILL EMPTY
SEATS IN CARS BUT IN FACT WHEN
WE DO GET DATA WHETHER IT'S FROM
A STUDY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
KENTUCKY UC DAVIS.
AND WHY YOU WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING IS THAT -- TNC IS
DECREASED TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
INCREASED VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
INCREASED CONGESTION AND
POTENTIALLY HAVE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS ON SAFETY -- AS WE
DESIGN OUR STREETS AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE SERVICES WE DELIVER
THIS DATA BECOMES REALLY
ESSENTIAL IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- PEOPLE HAVE GOOD CHOICES
AND THAT WE HAVE GOOD OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU WILL PAUSE AND TAKE
ROLE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SENATOR ABOUT YOUR BELL PRESENT
BATES.
IT'S PRESENT DOT.
DODD PRESENT GALGIANI.
JOHNNY PRESENT MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORRELL PRESENT ROTH.
ROTH PRESENT RUBIO SKINNER STONE.
STONE PRESENT AMBERG CASKEY.
THE COURT THANK YOU.
OKAY -- WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR PLEASE.
I'M CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
OKAY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
DAYS LATER CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
OF OKAY ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL -- KIND OF
SPEAKERS OPPOSING PLEASE COME
FOR PLEASE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THEY COME RIGHT UP HERE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
COURTNEY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET -- UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO AFTER THE JUNE
THIRD AMENDMENTS -- WE WERE NOT
MADE AWARE OF THESE AMENDMENTS
BEFORE THEY WENT INTO PLANTS
WHICH IS WHY ARE OPPOSITION IS
NOT REFLECTED IN YOUR ANALYSIS --
AND WE WERE DETERMINING THE
BROAD RANGE OF THE HEAD THERE
THE BRIDE -- LANGUAGE THAT WAS
IN THE BILL AFTER IT WENT INTO
PRINT ON JUNE THIRD AND DID GET
OUR LETTER IN TODAY SO WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATENESS ON
THAT BUT WE WERE.
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE THAT
WENT INTO PRINT ON JUNE THIRD TO
TRY TO DETERMINE THE IMPACT OF
THAT LANGUAGE -- THE RANGER
INDUSTRY ENABLES MOBILITY FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WITHIN
THESE PLATFORMS IS DATA THAT WE
UNDERSTAND CAN BE USEFUL FOR
PLANNING PURPOSES -- AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HOWEVER THESE USES
MUST BE BALANCED WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT RISK CREATED Y THE
SHARING OF GEO LOCATION AND
MOVEMENT DATA OF WRITERS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS.
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THESE RISKS
GIVEN THE NATURE AND SCOPE OF
THE DATA.
THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE SHARED
WITHOUT ANY PRE ESTABLISHED
PRIVACY SAFEGUARDS.
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO AS THE
WITNESSES -- TALKED ABOUT AS AN
AGGREGATED DE IDENTIFIED DATA
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY IN THIS BILL THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN PRINT IS A DETAILED --
TRIP DATA AND DETAILED TRIP DATA --
CAN CONTAIN SUCH THINGS AS
DETAILED ORIGIN AND DESTINATION
INFORMATION TIME STAMPS AND
MILES TRAVELED.
IT CAN BASICALLY BE USED TO
ESTABLISH AN INDIVIDUAL'S TRAVEL
PATTERNS AND POTENTIALLY REVEAL
SENSITIVE PERSONAL INFORMATION
OF EIGHTY WRITER -- FURTHER THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE CPUC TO
UNDERCUT AN EXISTING PROPOSED
RULING RELATED TO TNC DATA
SHARING BY REQUIRING TNC IS TO
SHARED AS I AS SAID DETAILED
TRIP DATA WITH VARIOUS STATE AND
LOCAL ENTITIESAND AN UNDEFINED
OTHER RELEVANT PARTIES -- FOR A
PURPOSE THAT IS ALSO NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED.
IT DOES NOT SPECIFY WHO THE
RECIPIENT RECIPIENTS THE DATA
ARE POTENTIALLY ALLOWING ANYONE
TO CLAIM ACCESS TO THIS HIGHLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION -- WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL BUT AS THIS
LANGUAGE DID GOING TO PLAN ON
JUNE THIRD WE DO THINK THAT IT
WOULD TAKE IT TAKES MORE TIME TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS ACTUALLY
MEANS.
I ALSO DO HAVE TO SAY THERE'S A
BILL THAT WAS AT SLATED BE HEARD
TODAY AB ELEVEN TWELVE WHICH WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MUCH MORE
NARROWLY TAILORED WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DATA SHARING.
I'M REQUIREMENTS IT IS ALSO
AUTHORED BY THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL -- AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR BUT
OUR HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT A LOT
OF THE LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY IN
THIS BILL ESPECIALLY THE
DETAILED TRIP INFORMATION -- WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE SPEAKING ON
KNOWLEDGE AND HIS BILL.
GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES -- WITH -- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
TECHNO AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS -- OTHERS
SPEAKERS PLEASE ANYBODY ELSE --
OKAY -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
PROPS YOU CAN RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE CONCERN I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THERE'S CLEARLY -- A VERY
STRONG RATIONALE FOR HAVING THE
STATE TO BE SHARED WITH PLANNING
AGENCIES IN WITH COMMUNITIES WE
NEED TO KNOW WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GOING UP WE'RE GOING TO ADD
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IF WE WERE
TO FILL ANY GAPS -- AND I WOULD
HATE TO THINK THAT CONCERNS
ABOUT PRIVACY AT THIS POINT
WOULD STOP OUR ABILITY TO DO
THAT WE CAN CERTAINLY WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
THE TECH COMMUNITY WITH ALL OF
THE TNC IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHAT THEY'RE COMFORTABLE AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO BREAK
ANY CALIFORNIA PRIVACY LAW SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEE WHOSE JURISDICTION
THIS IS UNDER. TO MAKE URE THAT
WHAT'S COLLECTED IS NOT
IDENTIFYING OF ANY INDIVIDUALS
THAT ANY PRIVACY CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED -- WE ARE -- PRO
TECHNOLOGY PRO FILLING IN THOSE
GAPS SO WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
TO HURT ANYBODY'S BUSINESS BUT
WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS. TO SOME DATA ABOUT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE TAKING TRIPS SO -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND WITH THAT I
WOULD REQUIRE REQUEST BELIEVE
REQUEST ALL OF YOU ALLOWING ME
TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE WITH
THEM BY PUTTING FOR THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU -- OKAY ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MY RECOMMENDATIONS -- MOTION
FAVOR THIS WILL GO TO RULES.
IF IT'S APPROVED [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY -- THE OTHER QUESTIONS WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT.
A BELL AYE BATES -- IT'S DOT.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE.
BROWN NO ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
SKINNER STONE.
STONE NO AMBER WHAT CASSIE.
YOUR FOR ROLES IN FAVOR WILL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE BILL THANK YOU
MY LAST BILL IS AB FORTINO SEVEN
ARE RECKLESS DRIVING AND STREET
RACING IS AN EPIDEMIC ACROSS OUR
STREETS IN LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
SEEN.
MULTIPLE DEATHS FROM BYSTANDERS
BECAUSE OF STREET RACING WHICH
SEEMS TO BE AN INCREASING
PROBLEM AND RECKLESS DRIVING IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST COMPLAINTS
THAT WE GET IN MY DISTRICT AND
ACROSS LOS ANGELES.
THIS BILL WE BELIEVE IS A
REASONABLE WAY OF STARTING TO
ADDRESS THOSE MORE CRIMES MORE
SERIOUSLY AND THESE ARE CRIMES
BY THE WAY THAT NOT JUST KILL
PEOPLE BUT THAT KEEP PARENTS
FROM.
ALLOWING THEIR CHILDREN JUST TO
ALK ON THE SIDEWALKS IN SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
AFRAID OF WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO
THEM WHAT THIS BILL SAYS THAT ON
THE SECOND CONVICTION NOW THIS
IS ON THE SECOND CONVICTION.
OF EITHER MISDEMEANOR LEVEL
RECKLESS DRIVING WHICH MEANS NOT
JUST ROLLING A STOP SIGN OR
MAKING A RIGHT WITHOUT LOOKING
THIS IS PEOPLE THAT ARE DRIVING
WITHOUT SUCH A WANTON DISREGARD
FOR HUMAN LIFE THAT IT BECOMES A
CRIME.
OR THE SECOND CONVICTION FOR
STREET RACING BUT YOUR CAR WILL
BE IMPOUNDED FOR THIRTY DAYS AND
YOU'LL HAVE TO REMOVE ANY
MODIFICATIONS FROM YOUR VEHICLE
THAT MAKE IT A RACING VEHICLE
AND NOT STREET LEGAL AND IT'S
THE FIRST TIME THAT THAT WOULD
BE IN LAW.
THAT YOU WILL GET YOUR VEHICLE
BACK UNLESS AS MODIFICATIONS ARE
REMOVED.
THERE'S A LOT OF OUTSOURCING
PEOPLE WHO NEED THE CAR TO GET
TO WORK OR FOR THE CAR OF A YOU
KNOW OF A TEENAGER BUT YOU KNOW.
THE PARENTS CAR THERE'S A LOT OF
SAFEGUARDS IN HERE TO PREVENT
HARDSHIP SOME PEOPLE BUT WHEN I
SPEAK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT MY
COMMUNITY WHAT THEY SAY IS THEY
ARE BUSTING THE SAME PEOPLE OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY'RE PAYING THE FINES BECAUSE
THEIR NOMINAL WITH THEY REALLY
CARE ABOUT IS THAT TRICKED OUT
VEHICLE AND THEY HAVE SUGGESTED
THIS IS A REMEDY TAKE THE CAR
AWAY FROM THIRTY DAYS DRIVING IS
A PRIVILEGE IT'S NOT A RIGHT.
AND IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE BEING
BAD BAD ENOUGH DRIVER THAT YOU
HAVE TWO CONVICTIONS FOR THIS WE
THINK THAT IMPOUNDING THE CARPET
THIRTIES MAYBE IS THE WAITED TO
TEACH A LESSON.
WITHOUT I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THE SPEAKERS ARE FAVOR PLEASE.
A MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIM
CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE AUTHOR -- WHEN
REGULAR FINDS DON'T DO THE TRICK
THEN WE BELIEVE THAT IMPOUNDMENT
IS A PROPER REMEDY IN THE
SITUATION EMPOWERMENT HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO WORK IN THE PAST AND
WE SUPPORT THIS PRESSURE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OTHER SPEAKERS.
SPEAKERS OPPOSE PLEASE
[inaudible]
SPEAKERS OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA -- WITH
REGARD TO IMPOUNDMENT THIS BILL
DOES ONE THING IT DENIES JUDGES
THE THE DISCRETION TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF TIME
IN OF EMPOWERMENT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT CURRENT
LAW ALREADY ALLOWS IMPOUNDMENT
OF THE VEHICLE USED IN RECKLESS
DRIVING OR IN A SPEED CONTEST
FOR PERIOD OF UP TO THIRTY DAYS --
INCLUDING THE THIRTY DAYS THAT
WOULD BE NOW MANDATED UNDER THIS
BILL.
AB FORTINO SEVEN REMOVES THE
COURT'S DISCRETION TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE PERIOD OF IN
TOWN AND AND INSTEAD REQUIRES
THE EMPOWERMENT FOR THE FULL
THIRTY DAYS FOR ANY SECOND
OFFENSE OF RECKLESS DRIVING OR
STREET RACING.
EMPOWERMENT OF A VEHICLE AND
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT IS FOR A
PERIOD AS LONG AS THIRTY DAYS
ALL TOO OFTEN BECOMES A DE FACTO
FORFEITURE.
AS MANY DEFENDANTS ARE UNABLE TO
PAY THE LARGE STORAGE FEES
CHARGED WHEN A VEHICLE IS HELD
FOR THAT LONG.
HERE THIS YEAR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
PUBLISHED A REPORT ENTITED
TOWED INTO DEBT -- THAT -- WENT
OVER THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS
THAT VEHICLE TOES AND IMPOUNDS
CAN HAVE ON INDIVIDUALS.
THAT REPORT FOUND THAT THE
AVERAGE STORAGE FEE IS FIFTY
THREE DOLLARS PER DAY -- EIGHT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND
TOWING FEES THAT WOULD ALSO
APPLY TO THESE IMPOUNDMENTS THE
TOTAL COST OF A THIRTY DAY ON
INCOME AND WILL BE ON AVERAGE
ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE DOLLARS.
AN AMOUNT MANY DEFENDANTS SIMPLY
WON'T BE ABLE TO PAY -- FOR MANY
OR MOST OF THOSE SUBJECT TO
THESE MANDATORY THIRTY DAYS IN
TOWN THAT THE RESULT WILL BE THE
LOSS OF THEIR CAR.
LOTS OF THE VEHICLE CAN THEN
RESULT IN A DEFENDANT LOSING A
JOB OR BEING UNABLE TO FULFIL
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES WELL THE
BILL DOES ALLOW THE JUDGE SOME
DISCRETION WHEN EMPOWERMENT WILL
RESULT IN HARDSHIP TO THE FAMILY.
IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE JUDGE TO
CONSIDER HARDSHIP TO THE
DEFENDANT OR WHETHER THE
DEFENDANT WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD
TO GET THE CAR BACK AFTER THIRTY
DAY IMPOUNDMENT.
JUDGES SHOULD RETAIN DISCRETION
TO DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
PENALTY IN EACH CASE WHICH AS I
STATED BEFORE WOULD INCLUDE AND
AND AN EMPOWERMENT OF THIRTY
DAYS WHERE THE OFFENSES AGREED
YES ODD DEPENDING ON THE
SITUATION OF THE DEFENDANT -- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL THERE'S A MOTION
[inaudible]
AND YOU HAVE A CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE IS HE HE'S HE'LL
USE OUR COMMENTS I DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO'S HAD THEIR
CAR TOWED BECAUSE IT WAS PARTING
CORRECTLY OR THEY HAVE UNPAID
FINES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE ACTING
WITH THEIR CAR IN A CRIMINAL WAY
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS IT'S ONE THING TO
MAKE A MISTAKE ONCE AND HAVE A
CONVICTION.
THIS BILL IT WAS ALL ONLY TAKES
EFFECT ON THE SECOND CONVICTION
AND AT THAT POINT SOMEONE
CLEARLY HASN'T GOTTEN THE
MESSAGE WHAT ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT TO WALK
DOWN THE STREET.
WHAT ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO KNOW THAT IF THEY
STOP AT A STOP SIGN AND PROCEED
FOR THE NOT GOING TO GET HIT BY
SOMEONE IS DRIVING A HUNDRED
MILES AN HOUR?
IN A RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD
WHICH IS THE TYPE OF THING THAT
PEOPLE GET RECKLESS DRIVING --
OF TICKETS FOR AND THESE
VEHICLES THAT ARE USED IN STREET
RACING ARE. SIX BIGGER CARS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVELY WORKED ON
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE THAT ARE
DRIVING THEIR CAR TO WORK
THEY'RE ENGAGING IN WHAT
SOMETIMES A PROFIT MAKING
ENTERPRISES BY TURNING OUR
STREETS INTO THE FACTORY SINGS
ON SO THAT THEY CAN CHARGE MONEY
FOR PEOPLE TOOK TO WATCH.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE COMMENTS AND
I DO HAVE SYMPATHY FOR PEOPLE
BUT I ALSO WANT TO PROTECT --
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS WITHOUT I
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THERE GALGIANI.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I TRIED WITH
THIS LAST YEAR AND DIDN'T QUITE
MAKE IT THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT
SINCE THAT TIME THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN WORSE AND WE'VE SEEN AN
EXCLAMATION.
IN THE PROBLEM AND WE'VE SEEN AN
ESCALATION THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES AND PARTICIPANTS
INVOLVED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TONIGHT HOPEFULLY THIS TIME --
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO TAKE THE BILL
ALL THE WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK AND GET IT SIGNED.
SO MUCH SENATOR.
I WOULD RECOMMEND IN FAVOR OF IT --
I RECALL A TIRED SENATOR DRIVING
THROUGH.
CENTER WHAT CAO SKIS DISTRICT.
IN FREMONT MILPITAS WHICH IS
NORTH KOREA'S. FOR THIS RIGHT.
ABOUT A MINUTE.
AND DRIVING HOME AFTER A LONG
SENATE MEETING. ONE NIGHT.
AND SAWYER CHEN I'D VOTE.
MAYBE WE CAN HELP CENTER WHAT
KOWSKI -- CONTROL THE TRAFFIC
BETTER. TO CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO. SEVEN OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES.
DON AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
SKINNER STONE.
STONE I AMBER AMBER I WOULD
TRUST ME.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THANK YOU ALL THE TWO LOOKS SOME.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE ITEMS
THAT WERE.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM TWO WELL THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IS HERE.
HE PRESENTED THE PRIOR TO SEVEN
QUORUM SO -- ITEM THREE ON THE
AGENDA.
WHICH IS -- AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE
RECOMMEND A MOTION FAVOR
[inaudible]
SOME OF THAT'S YOUR BILL.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT I FELT I BATES DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
ROSS ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER.
STONE.
STONE NO NUMBER.
I'M BURKE I WILL TRUST ME.
CASSIE I BROWN [inaudible]
AROUND NOW [inaudible]
THE STATE. TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE BATES NOW.
THE THREE OF SIX WAS IN FAVOR.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE BILL -- AND WE
HAD ONE OTHER ITEM BEFORE WE GO
ON THE NEXT AUTHOR.
ITEM -- NUMBER ONE WE HAD A
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL.
THIS IS A. B.. ONE EIGHT FIVE
SALIM EVER GRAYSON.
ABOUT JOINT MEETINGS SO.
WITH TO SEE TO SEE AN A. R. B.
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING
COMMITTEE BOWMAN [inaudible]
AND WE HAD A RECOMMENDATION OF
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. FOR
MOTION SUCH A CASE WE HAVE A
VOTE ON THIS PLEASE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOME A MEMBER GRAYSON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT.
WELL I BATES HI BATES I DON.
DODD AYE GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE MCGUIRE MOREAU.
MORRELL NO ROSS ROTH AYE RUBIO
SKINNER STONE.
STONE NO -- BURKE NUMBER I WILL
COST ME.
BECAUSE HE AYE. SIX SEVENTY TWO
TO BE OF SERVICE IN FAVOR --
WILL RELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN ON
THAT BILL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE HAVE.
WE'LL GO TO NEXT ITEM MEMBER.
OF ROBERT RIVAS SIR ROBERT.
THEN ROBERT HAS -- A. B. --
TWELVE SIXTY SIX YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT IS GREAT TO
BE HERE WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON
I APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT --
TO SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SIXTY SIX AND SO
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK -- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK OF
PREPARING THE ANALYSIS AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT
FULL EXPLANATION OF WHAT THIS
BILL AIMS TO DO -- AND SO
CERTAINLY AS WAS STATED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- MISTER CHAIR I AM
PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS -- SO STAFF I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU -- AND
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE VEHICLES MORE MOTORISTS
ON THE ROAD THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT --
SOME DATA.
OUR STATE HAS THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF BICYCLE -- THE
COMMUTERS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF IS A STATE IT
SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE.
OUT OF THIS POLICY MAKERS.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR FIRST EVER
STATEWIDE PLAN. FOR ACTIVE MODES
OF TRANSPORTATION A STATEWIDE
PLANET WITH A GOAL OF THEM OF OF
OF PROVIDING ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH ROBUST MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS -- AND
WELL EXPAND IT SAYS IS SUCH
OPTIONS IT IS CERTAINLY A GOOD
THING -- IT IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY. TO
IMPROVING CREATE SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS ENVIRONMENTS --
THAT WILL ACCOMMODATE BOTH
MOTORIZED TRAFFIC AND CYCLISTS.
AND SO OVER TEN YEARS AGO I WAS --
A PAY CALL FIREFIGHTER INSIDE
OUT TO PAY CALL FIREFIGHTER FOR
ABOUT SIX YEARS OF MY LIFE.
IN THOSE TIMES I WAS ON DUTY AND
HOW TO RESPOND TO A VEHICLE
VERSE -- A PEDESTRIAN ACCIDENT.
ALMOST EVERY SITUATION EVERY
ACCIDENT I RESPONDED.
TO HAD OCCURRED AT A TRAFFIC
INTERSECTION.
AND SO THIS EXPERIENCE MY TIME
AS A PAY CALL FIREFIGHTER --
MOTIVATED ME TO INTRODUCE HIS
BILL.
I IN A MOTIVATED ME BECAUSE THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL TOSS IT IS TWELVE
SIXTY SIX WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO
IMPROVE SAFETY.
AND REDUCE CONFUSION FOR BOTH
DRIVERS AND CYCLISTS WHEN
APPROACHING TRAFFIC
INTERSECTIONS.
AND SO FOR MOST INTERSECTIONS IN
OUR STATE BIKE LANES AND
ABRUPTLY.
THE END OF BROCCOLI UPON MERGING
INTO THE ITH A RIGHT TURN LANE
OR IN SOME CASES IF IT'S A ONE
WAY STREET A LEFT TURN LANE.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
AND THE ANALYSIS STAFF TO
FANTASTIC JOB AND TRY TO EXPLAIN
IT SO BEAR WITH ME AS I TRY TO
PAINT YOU A PICTURE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS IT
WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WITH A TOOL WITH THIS NEW OPTION.
A SAFER OPTION THAT WOULD ALLOW
A SHARED AT LANE CONCEPT.
AND THAT IS A RIGHT TURN LANE OR
IN THE CASE OF A ONE WAY STREET
A LEFT TURN LANE.
THESE TURN LANES WOULD ALSO
CONSIST OF A BY CALLING A BIKE
LANE THAT WOULD BE LOCATED ON
THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF WHERE THE
VEHICLE WOULD BE MAKING THEIR
INTENDED TURN SO ON THE OUTSIDE.
OF THE THE OUTSIDE PORTION OF
THE LINE AND SO THIS THIS TYPE
OF A DESIGN WOULD DIRECT DRIVERS
AND CYCLISTS ON SAFE PASSED
THROUGH INTERSECTIONS.
SO CYCLIST TRAVELING THROUGH AN
INTERSECTION WOULD BE GUIDED TO
TRAVEL ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF
WHERE THE VEHICLE WOULD BE
MAKING THEIR INTENDED TURN --
AND SO THIS BILL -- WOULD
FURTHER REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION TO DEVELOP THE
STANDARDS I BELIEVE -- THE
STANDARD WOULD BE OR THE
PROPOSED ENERGY IS TO HAVE THE
PAVEMENT MARKINGS. TO IMPLEMENT
THIS TOOL FOR A SAFER BY PLANE
OPTION.
THROUGHOUT OUR INTERSECTIONS IN
THE STATE SO WITH THAT -- I
APPRECIATE THE TIME STATURE.
AND TO HAVE BILL SPONSORED.
MY NAME IS DAVE SNYDER THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS THAT SAID
IT WELL.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF FIXING A
PROBLEM WHERE THE COMMON SENSE
AND SAFE BEHAVIOR IS NOT
PROVIDED GUIDANCE FOR AND IS NOT
TECHNICALLY LEGAL THIS REQUIRES
CALTRANS.
TO BY DESIGN GUIDANCE SO THAT IT
IT'S LEGAL AND SAFE TO DO WHAT
MAKES SENSE WHEN A BIKE RIDER
PARTISAN INTERSECTION.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS UP.
CAN I AS A QUESTION -- IN TERMS
OF THE DESIGN -- ONE THING I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT BY BIKE
THE BIKE LINES LANES IS.
WHEN PEOPLE OPEN THEIR DOOR?
IF THERE PARK NEXT TO A BI PLANE
AND THEY OPEN THE DOOR INTO THE
BIKE LANE.
IS THAT -- AN ACCIDENT ITS
FREQUENT.
IN TERMS OF CYCLISTS BEEN HIT BY
A DOORS IS.
FROM FROM YOUR STANDPOINT.
I'M OF THE DESIGN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW YOU DESIGN SAFE BY
COINCIDENCE.
I'M.
REALLY SORRY TO SAY THAT YEAH
IT'S A VERY FREQUENT ACCENT AND
I I KNOW OF SOMEONE WHO.
DIED IN SAN FRANCISCO -- ABOUT A
MONTH AGO SWERVING TO AVOID THAT
VERY SITUATION AND GETTING RUN
OVER BY A TRUCK IN THE LIKE THE
PERSON JUST.
OPENS THE THERE'S A BIKE LANE
NEXT TO THE PARKING SPACE ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE CAR.
THEY OPEN THE DOOR.
AND THEN THE BICYCLUS.
HITS THE DOOR BECAUSE THE THERE
WAS NO.
LOOKING OVER THE SHOULDER OR
WHATEVER A WELL DESIGNED BIKE
LANE.
IS OUTSIDE OF THE DESERT DOORS
ZONE WHERE THAT CAN HAPPEN
UNFORTUNATELY.
MANY IF NOT MOST BIKE LANES ARE
NOT ARE NOT.
DESIGNED THAT WELL.
THERE'S ANOTHER SOLUTION AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH YOUR
PERMISSIONS VERY SLIGHTLY OFF
TOPIC -- THANK CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
COULD PUT IN ITS GUIDANCE IN ITS
ADVICE -- ADVICE FOR MOTORISTS
TO OPEN THEIR CAR DOOR WITH
THEIR RIGHT HAND IN A SET OF THE
TRANSCRIPTS THE SO CALLED DUTCH
REACH EXACTLY ALIKE THE BUT THEY
REQUIRE IN THE NETHERLANDS AND
YOU LOOK.
YOU CAN SEE BEHIND YOU WHEN YOU
OPEN YOUR DOOR RIGHT EXACTLY IF
YOU FORCES THE DRIVER DID.
YOU OPEN THE DOOR WITH YOUR LEFT
HAND WHEN YOU TAKE A DRIVER'S
TEST AND EVELYN YOU FAIL YOUR
DRIVER'S TEST.
SO HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH STATEN.
JUST GET HIM TO PUT THAT IN
THERE THAT WOULD MANUAL YEAH
THAT WOULD WHAT MAYBE IT MAYBE I
LIKE I LIKE SUGGESTS A BREAKDOWN
BASED ON TAKE A NOTE ROBERTS.
RIVAS IS BILL.
THE WE SUGGESTED NOT PARTY BILL
NECESSARILY BUT THE DMV INCLUDE.
A SAFE THE DOOR OPENING OF THE
RIVER THE DUTCH REACH IN THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE MANUAL.
WE'LL PURSUE THAT OKAY.
BECAUSE I TAKE I TAKE THAT
SHOULD BE DONE.
HE SAID THERE IS ALREADY SOME
DEATHS.
OKAY SO WE GET TO MAKE IT TO ME
I I THINK WE ARE A THE WHOLE
IDEA PREVENTION RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
SO -- ANYWAY I THOUGHT A RAISE
THAT ISSUE I A I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE SOLUTION WAS THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER MEMBERS OKAY -- WE HAVE
OPPOSITION TO THIS [inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SENATE -- OKAY ANY QUESTIONS
FROM OUR COMMITTEE.
DONE AND WILL LET OFFER CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IN FAVOR
OF THIS MOTION [inaudible]
SARAH BURKE.
THEY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ABOUT I FELL AYE BATES
[inaudible]
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
I ROTH RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
STONE NO ON BURKE.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY BECAUSE HE
AYE. SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU -- THIRD.
OKAY WE WILL GO TO THE CONCERNED
COUNTER THIS EMOTION.
CENTER STONE MOVES -- CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE'RE MAKING A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CENTER STONE
MAKES THE MOTION.
AND I WANT EXPLAINED BECAUSE
SHE'S THE ONE THAT WANTS TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
CENTER SCANNER WE HAVE DIVIDED
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY CONSENT COUNTER A IN
CONSENT COUNTER BE.
CONSENT COUNTER A CONSIST OF A.
B.. TWO FIVE TWO AB THREE THREE
FIVE SB SIX THIRTY FOUR A. B..
NINE NINE EIGHT AN A. B. ONE
ZERO EIGHT NINE TEN A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE THAT'S THE MOTION.
CENTER STONE CORRECT.
OKAY WILL CALL THE ROLL ON THAT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS TWO FIVE
SIX SEVEN EIGHT AND ELEVEN
SENATOR ABOUT.
WELL I BATES DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE ROSS.
RUBIO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE.
STONE I AMBER AMBER I WOULD
TRUST ME WE GOT THE AYE. TO THE
SECOND CONSENT COUNTER CONCERNS
OF ACR. FOR THIRTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR FORTY SEVEN AND SIXTY SIX
WE HAVE PULLED ACR.
SEVENTEEN OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
ONE IS GOING TO PRESENT THAT.
SO WILL WILL HAVE A MOTION ON
THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
UNLESS YOU WANT [inaudible]
WHAT?
ONE ITEM TWENTY ACR SIXTY SIX I
WOULD VOTE YES ON ME PULL THAT.
ONE ACR.
SIXTY SIX FERTILE WILL PULL THAT
OFF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND MOTIONS FOR THE BALANCE SO
WE WILL NOT INCLUDE.
ACR.
SEVENTEEN AND ACR [inaudible]
SIXTY SIX CHOLERA PLEASE.
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES.
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE.
BOROUGH.
MORRELL AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO SKINNER.
STONE STONE I AMBER AMBER I WILL
CASTING BECAUSE HE AYE.
I WOULD MOVE ACR SIXTY SIX OR DO
WE HAVE TO JUST HOLD IT OVER.
SINCE WE HAVE PEOPLE JUST WALKED
OUT.
OKAY WILL WILL HOLD HOLD THE
BILL.
THEN IF WE PULL IT WE HAVE TO
REQUEST A MEMBER BE PRESENT --
OKAY SO.
IF YOU WANT TO ONE SEPARATELY
THAT'S FINE BUT IF YOU.
I JUST WANT TO BURDEN IT
SEPARATELY OKAY.
THAT'S ALL I WANTED TO MAKE A
MOTION THAT.
I WOULD MOVE -- INSECT OUR ITEM.
SIX TAKEN CENTER ITEM -- TWENTY
ACR SIXTY SIX THERE'S A MOTION.
I JUST WANT A SEPARATE VOTE ON
IT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WHO JUST LOST A LOT OF MEMBERS?
THIS IS A SIMPLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH A RECOMMENDATION
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR FELL I FELL AYE BATES
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORALE.
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE STONE.
NUMBER WE COUNTY.
WHY BROWN I TYPE -- NOW.
WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WELCOME. SEVEN
ONE ONE WHERE IS HERE TO PRESENT%
HE'S HERE [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ON NOVEMBER SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SERGEANT BRAUN HILLIS
WAS SHOT WHILE RESPONDING TO AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER AT THE BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL IN THOUSAND OAKS.
WE WILL NEVER KNOW HOW MANY
LIVES WERE SAVED BY HIS
COURAGEOUS CHOICE. TO ENTER AND
CONFRONT THE SHOOTER.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT HIS DECISION
WAS THE ULTIMATE ACT OF SERVICE
[inaudible]
AND SACRIFICE.
ACR SEVENTEEN WILL NAME A THREE
POINT FOUR MILE PORTION OF US
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE IN VENTURA
COUNTY IN HIS HONOR.
BORN AND RAISED IN CANOGA PARK
CALIFORNIA RON JOINED THE
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY TO
PROTECT AND GIVE BACK TO HIS
COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION TO HIS YEARS OF HIS
EIGHT YEARS OF SERVICE WITH THE
VENTURA COUNTY STE SPOT TEAM HE
ALSO COACHED AND MENTOR.
TO HUNDREDS OF DEPUTIES THROUGH
HIS WORK AS A SELF DEFENSE AND
CONCEALED CARRY WEAPONS TRAINING
OFFICER.
TRAGICALLY HIS LIFE WAS CUT
SHORT.
APPROXIMATELY ONE YEAR BEFORE
RETIREMENT.
SERGEANT HILLIS WAS KNOWN AS A
KIND COMPASSIONATE AND CARING
INDIVIDUAL.
WHO DEEPLY LOVES HIS WIFE KAREN
AND SON JORDAN?
HE IS TRULY WORTHY OF THIS
DEDICATION IN HIS MEMORY.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
SIGNAGE FOR THIS DEDICATION WILL
BE ERECTED UPON RECEIVING
DONATIONS FROM NON STATE SOURCES
TO COVER SO SHADED COSTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH THAT'S BEEN --
SOME BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WINS --
BRINGING FOR THIS -- CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION -- THIS REPRESENTS A
VERY TRAGIC DAY OUR COMMUNITY IS
STILL REELING.
FROM THE BORDERLINE SHOOTING AND
WE THINK THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
RECOGNITION OF THE SERVICE
SACRIFICE AND COMMITMENT OF UP
VENTURA COUNTY SERGEANT HE LISTS --
AND I WANTED TO BE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WAS AWARE AS WELL THAT
OF THE COUNTY.
AND THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS
HAVE AGREED TO SHARE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DEDICATION
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IN THE COMMENTS SO.
YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PLUGINS OFFICE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF THOUSAND OAKS WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SIMPLY ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE COUNTY.
AND THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- ONE
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE --
THEY WERE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- THIS IS -- VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
BECAUSE MY BROTHER HAPPENED
UNKNOWN NUMBER THE FAMILY MY
BROTHER WORKS IN. FOR THE WINTER
COUNTY.
SUIT IS COUNTY PRINTER.
IN THOSE MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY
SO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS.
RESOLUTION ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE SIDE
OF THE EMOTION THANK YOU.
LOCAL REAL THIS IS ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN
BY SOME OF THE MEMBER OR WHEN
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CENTER B<c.cyan>.</c>
WELL I BATES DODD HI DON AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE
MORALE.
I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STONE NUMBER WHAT
CASTING.
WE HAVE SIX SCHOOLS WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE PRESS OR THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATORS -- OKAY WE'RE
GOING.
TO WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES WE HAVE
SOME PEOPLE.
IN JUDICIARY VOTING AND THEY'RE
COMING BACK NOW THERE ARE
[inaudible]
THE COUPLE [inaudible]
THAT.
HI WE NAMED AFTER.
ONE THE ONE THE VOTERS
[inaudible]
OKAY OKAY
WIRES.
WITH THE CALL. ONE OF THE CALL
ON THE BILL'S.
CHOOSE THE PLAN THAT'S RIGHT.
NEXT. TO IT
[inaudible]
YES.
JUST WAIT JUST A SECOND WILL
HAVE THE CORNER.
WE CAN VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE PHARMACY [inaudible]
WHICH IS.
THANK YOU SEE THAT [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WHEN?
REALLY LOVE AWFUL.
ACTUALLY I WAS ON THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
RESEARCH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
IF.
YEAH HI MARTY.
JUDGE JUDGE OR ONE OF OUR THE
PRESIDENT.
HAS BUILT UP IT JUST.
MIGHT NOT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THERE.
THE ONLY BOB
-- WHERE WE TAKE TO
ORDER THE BILLS AND FILE ORDER?
AND WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE
SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO SKINNER.
SKINNER I NINETY TWO NOW THAT AS
NINE VOTES IN FAVOR [inaudible]
PASSAGE.
ABOUT SAYS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY SEVEN
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I BY SURE
VOTING NO SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO SKINNER -- I
DOES EIGHT VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE
MOTION PASSED.
THIS IS A FAMILY BILL ELEVEN
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE.
BATES NO RATES NOW MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL COUNTY.
BY COUNTY I THAT'S ALWAYS GOING.
TO THAT IS EIGHT VOTES IN FAVOR
MOTION CARRIES.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIRED
RUNNING I BATES.
NO BATES NO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible] TO TO
NINE VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE
MOTION CARRIES.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY [inaudible]
GERMANY.
NINE BATES HI BATES AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO SKINNER. TEN
VOTES IN FAVOR THAT CARRIES.
HERS.
THIS IS A FAMILY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN BY SOME A
MEMBER -- ON THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
VOTING AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO STONE.
AMBER AMBER I WOULD COUNTY.
ACROSS THE AYE. TEN BOWLS IN
FAVOR MOTION CARRIES.
ON THE FIRST CONSENT.
ON THE FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS TWO
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT AND ELEVEN
GERMANY HI.
BATES HI BATES AYE AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
ELEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS A PRINT.
ON THE SECOND.
ON THE SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SURE VOTING AYE.
BATES HI BETH I MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER. TEN
VOTES IN FAVOR MOTION CARRIES.
YOU CAN DO A FAIR.
SIXTY SIX THIS IS ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX
THE MOTION AS IT BE ADOPTED AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH RECOMMENDATION TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BATES FIVE BATES AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE ROSS.
ROTH AYE RUBIO STONE.
AMBER.
AMBER I WOULD COUNTY.
HI KATHY AYE. TWO ZERO TWO ZERO
OKAY -- THAT WERE DONE
[inaudible]
MEETINGS JR